ماذا حدثتي من طاد الصين عدل الجيش
الامريكي نظام الرادار لجعله اكثر حساسيه
نتيجه لذلك زاد عدد ما تم رصده كما ذكرنا
ظهرت ثلاثه اجسام غريبه اخرى لكن لماذا
عدلت واشنطن الانظمه الان شعرت بالاحراج
من تكرار الامر المنطاد الاول مثلا ظل في
السماء لمده اسبوع كامل حسابات الولايات
المتحده مع الصين باتتاثر تعقيدا مقارنه
بحبها البارده مع موسكو سلاح الاقتصاد
الذي مثل افضليه كبرى لواشنطن على حساب
الشيوعيه السوفييتيه فيما مضى بات اليوم
يعطي افضليا بكين فمحاولات واشنطن لن تنجح
في فصل اقتصادها عن الصين من خلال وسائل
السياسيه مثل قيود السفر وحظر التكنولوجيا
والحواجز التجاريه ومن يقول ذلك مستشار
الامن القومي ومناسق البيت الابيض للقضايا
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ اقل مشترك لجيك صلب
نشرته فورن ايفرز في اكتوبر
وتسعه عشر وحتى التعريفات الجمركيه قد
تصبح ميزه للصين على المدى الطويل عبر
دفعها للاعتماد الذاتي اكثر كما يحدث الان
في صناعه الرقائق يصعب على واشنطن تجاهل
حقيقه ان الصين هي ثاني اكبر حائز لسندات
الخزانه الامريكيه ومستثمر كبير في
الاوراق الماليه الامريكيه الاخرى وكما
كشفت الاعوام القليله الماضيه اقرب حلفاء
واشنطن ليسوا مستعدين لمواجهه الصين او
تفكيكها اقتصاديا على نطاق واسع ولنا في
عام 2020 مثال تفوقت الصين على واشنطن
باعتبارها الشريك التجاري الاكبر للاتحاد
الاوروبي وحتى على المستوى الشعبي لا يرى
المواطن الامريكي بكين كعدو مباشر كما راى
موسكو استطلاعا للرائي في نوفمبر الماضي
لا يؤيد الاغلبيه سيناريو التدخل المباشر
لردع الصين في حال مهاجمتها تايوان او
الاستثمار الطويل المدى للتنافس مع الصين